[Applause]
all right what else is happening ellen's
gone
ellen we got that [__] out of here is
she really out of here for real she out
she's gone she says she wants out
they're already searching for
replacements it's a rep really
yeah interesting
that was us we did that we did it yeah
the tricky thing with ellen is like
she's done undeniable good yeah
i think our only issue with her is she
we felt betrayed we felt like she was
this good person and she's not
the same thing is gonna happen to james
corden i actually like seven
or six years ago or something i was
working with a guy who wrote on james
corden's show yeah and someone someone's
like is he nice he seems nice and dead
ass he goes
nah man it's like the ellen thing where
they pretend to be super nice but
they're not
like six seven years ago he compared him
to ellen oh [__]
and then i was looking on twitter and
somebody had like the top
reddit comment on his ama was like yo
i went to this thing where you there was
a bunch of celebrities there and you
were also there and you were the most
massively entitled [__] to the wait
staff i've ever seen in my life
and like somebody else is there like
bieber and they said they're like bieber
was so friendly why were you like that
and that's his own ama this same [__] is
gonna come out about cordon
and i don't i think anybody who does
this show daytime tv
that tries to be all nice nobody can be
that nice all this [__] is gonna come
out about him
maybe it won't be ellen level but it's
gonna the same thing is gonna repeat as
long as we expect this corny ass
pandering ass tv
maybe the only people that can like be
nice
every single day for an hour or two
hours however long these shows are
every single day for two hours a day is
it yeah
two hours an hour an hour
maybe the only people can do that are
the people who've been faking it already
yeah
you know yeah authentically nice people
are authentic i'm a human i got
my emotions go up and down yeah do this
all the time put on this face come dance
like a [__] idiot yeah though i don't
see jimmy falling being a dick
i don't see with fallon also i was
thinking about that with conan i've
heard nothing but good things yeah i
don't see conan being a dick so i guess
it exists but it's tough
and conan at least gets to be he at
least back in the day was a little edgy
with his show
like in the 90s he was on at midnight
because it was edgier than what
lightning was doing or even what
letterman was doing
yeah it's interesting to see what
happens with ellen right because he or
she does all this stuff for gay rights
and like she did kind of brave things
like coming out on her show
losing all of her [__] supporters
then having this resurgence and daytime
television
pretty amazing mm-hmm you shouldn't be
allowed to look her in the eye actually
say again you probably shouldn't be
allowed to look her in the eye she's
right yeah she's right yeah but at the
same time i've
never heard a good story about her talk
to a friend who was on her show
yeah and he was like dog she berated
[__] like top to bottom
i heard stories and then saw it myself
it was unreal my girl
is from santa barbara yeah so her family
still lives out there
right and ellen is from santa barbara or
lives in santa barbara
montecito specifically they haven't
heard a single
nice story you see her around all the
time no no no
like mean to the pharmacist
means to the waiters mean to the just a
[__]
[__] raging [__] i've yet to hear a
single nice story about ellen this is
unbelievable because now i've been
looking for it
yeah now i'm asking around i'm not going
what a [__] i'm going hey
is it unfair what they're doing to her
and everybody i ask
is like no this woman is bona fide
mean that's crazy so it's like all right
you got it
you got it i guess you can get got but i
don't know who you're going to get to
fill in
like i want to take her aside but if
he's actually also a dick and more of
these ama type comments start coming out
then what i don't think i don't think
the person that you get like i think the
person you get just has to be good at
filling that role like i don't think
that we're going to find anything about
their personality why not get family and
i think
hung over in the daytime you say what
why not get fallen maybe i'm over early
maybe
but like first of all it's an amazing
time in history where like
the daytime show is more covered than
late night like that's how far late
night has fallen the [__] off yeah
is that all these late night hosts are
dying to get rid of their shows so they
could do this daytime thing
but what's her name uh the fat guy
gordon
corden has the perfect show it's just
games it's just eating weird foods it's
just like
antics that's all it is that's why i
thought fallon could could do it because
fallon
created that format right and then he
seems like a genuinely nice guy from
what i hear i hear he's a boozehound but
whatever that's not like you're a bad
person
yeah so i think he could be a great just
do that
why not cancel the show like are they
gonna call that's too much money are
they gonna call it ellen still
no but he's doing james corden like no
no i just
you know why i would take this that's
what i'm saying like why don't they just
cancel the show then refill the slot
like
they're gonna do this i think that's
what they're doing they're just gonna
get a refill for this but are they gonna
like change out
the whole set like it's not gonna be
called ellen yeah i know that's not true
are they just trying to it's gonna be
basically the same show
but different hosts different name i
think different set
basically whatever you're thinking
they're going to do is they're going to
do okay yeah i think they're just going
to have james corden be the
whatever and then imagine late night who
fills in in that role
you think they're going to do is just
some token [__] like they did with like
your girl lily
probably that was just also a brilliant
move for nbc
like yeah you're not look how woke we
are bisexual
indian female and we're gonna keep it on
the air no matter what people say about
it we're gonna keep it on the air
because it's on so late
the stakes are incredibly low we prop
she's replacing carson daly
have you ever given a [__] about who's
on carson daly's show no and i've been
on it
and i said that knowing that
he's happy i've been for you yeah yeah
yeah but
perfect and now you look super woke you
don't just keep the show on the air
we look so woke having it i think
they're going to do a similar thing with
gordon
but maybe a little bit higher bar
because he's not on as late
hmm and why wouldn't they just do some
token [__] with ellen's time slot
just because it's so coveted because
daytime i think
people who watch daytime tv want to see
white faces
uh wanna see what white faces
really i think so so they couldn't just
put on some tokens who's the most
popular
show outside of ellen oprah you had to
judy
oprah outside of oprah oprah gone
but outside of that it was i don't know
the [__] is his name comedian steve
harvey steve harvey oh yeah
it's the biggest man in daytime i
thought they canceled the show
steve harvey yeah i think i don't think
he has a show anymore
look that up he only he got
into a little trouble and then i think
the only show he has now is family food
what about the radio show
i don't even know yet can me too cost
you a radio gig
i feel like they're like are you good
man everybody looking at you yeah
just dying already they don't care
but like i feel like they should just do
some token [__] in ellen's slot or just
but
it's also let's say this even if it's
not racial it's a massive like that show
is a
massive show so we can't just flippantly
give that to somebody i would just take
carson daly wasn't getting ratings who
cares right ellen was getting ratings
making money
we need somebody that can make money
let's take race out of it i'll take that
back james corden
people love him he can do exactly that
kind of show he slides right in let's go
i don't think he probably shows canceled
last year but now he
he has a facebook only show now facebook
i okay do you want to go conspiracy
again
why not oh i'll give a little conspiracy
sometimes when these people get me tooed
or they get out of here like people get
[__] over like that
i think it's the network trying to save
money
like when ellen has her contract to make
however
money that she has to make and the
network's not making any money because
nobody watches [__] tv anymore
people are on instagram or people on
youtube or people or whatever
you know i mean like bill o'reilly was
making what 20 30 40 grand
40 million dollars a year they got this
young stud
way more handsome just as eloquent named
tucker carlson
and they're like we could feed him the
same talking points we're feeding bill
yeah and we could save tons of [__]
money yeah
why don't we get bill the [__] out of
here oh here hey bill here's this old me
too
that we probably knew about forever you
gotta retire sorry
i think there's validity to that matt
lauer same [__]
making crazy money get out of here megan
kelly had the crazy
contract with nbc after fox news i think
it was nbc he still got paid heavy
though still you out of here
yeah you still you're out here you're
not on the hook and i think like um
like nike and even clothing brands do
the same thing so they just wait for
somebody
to slip up and say the wrong thing so
they can cancel that contract
because it was like when they signed
them they was hot and gay but you know
where i got this from
i got this from mikko grimes mikko was
telling us about
nfl nfl players and they do this with
tons of different athletes
all of a sudden it's your contract here
you stop getting the ball thrown to you
so much
all of a sudden it's your contract here
and you're a defensive end
and uh or what does he play he's a d
back right yeah yeah
you're a d back and all of a sudden they
start making you travel all of a sudden
they start making you go
guard the number one every single play
no matter what they're trying to make it
look like you're getting
balls caught on you all the time you
know what i mean like they're doing
whatever they can if they know they're
not going to win
to reduce their salary for the next year
yeah and
if it happens in sports why wouldn't it
happen in media
these are massive contracts yeah no i i
believe there's something to that the
other thing though is this kind of took
on a life of its own
on twitter because one thread went viral
and
even our video it's at like what 1.3
million views before all this [__] broke
so i don't think that's nbc or whatever
the [__] network she's on being like
hey pump this this flagrant ii clip i
think that's just people were interested
in it was a story that just
yeah it's a story that's just like what
ellen and that's interesting because i
think she's so nice and so helpful she's
white oprah
she's a [__] let me see what this is
about yeah and then you get emotionally
invested you're like i feel betrayed by
this [__]
[__] you and then it kind of has its own
legs but i do see
possibility for yo she's expensive let's
try to get her out
yeah it's like what's the purpose
daytime television doesn't make money as
like it used to and we're paying you
like it made money like it used to
so something's got to give here and you
are going to be the one that gives
i would actually think daytime tv is
still the one of all tv that is making
any kind of money or effectiveness
that's not the argument
it's daytime tv the argument was not
making what it used to
fair and you're getting paid based on
what it used to be now my only
question with that is if you get fired
do you still have to pay the full
contract
i don't know because i think megan kelly
got her full contract i don't know
again i don't know but the problem that
i that the problem is
you have to pay that full contract with
something in that time slot that doesn't
get views
so now you can't get revenue for that
time slot so why not put something else
in there that actually gets revenue
because that was getting no views and
now i can generate enough revenue to pay
this [__] and whoever the next person
is
you can't just have nothing there right
making zero money right
but i don't know i don't again i don't
know if you have to pay that person at
full yeah the only thing with the ellen
thing that would make me think that's
not the case is that one person would be
like
yo she's getting [__] over she's
actually great everyone's lying but
i think she's a genuine [__] but what
i've realized about hollywood is
they'll protect people that make them
money like that's what we saw if
everybody knew about this louis thing
forever
nobody didn't know about louis the
floodgates are full and then they just
decide to open it and exactly they
stopped protecting i guarantee
that there were people stopping the
louis rumors
from coming to new york times or l.a
times or whatever it was
because everybody in comedy had heard
the rumor everybody and any comic that
said they had it
is lying to you can we you heard it i
heard it from you
years before i heard it yeah can we be
even more
keep even more a buck his manager was
apparently
involved in the cover-up you ain't
nobody left this [__] he reps
everybody he reps
woke ass issa ray he webs he reps kevin
hart he's the guy
dave becky is the [__] guy and this
[__] broke about louie
nobody's leaking stories that he helped
protect nobody's leaving this
[__]
nobody's saying anything today becky
because dave becky makes them and you
money
if i was rubbed by dave becky i wouldn't
be having this conversation no
so i think it's just one of those things
where like
the industry no matter what industry
you're in protects the people that make
money yeah second you stop
making money for somebody all of a
sudden
[__] gets a little sticky for you to
your point also if i fire this person
after this controversy
what show is everybody gonna start
watching as soon as we replace this this
human being
that show what's happening everybody's
going to watch james corden's first few
episodes on
on an ellen time slot like we got her
out
and the new person is going to come into
a ratings bonanza because [__] her she's
out
this guy's a nice guy let's watch his
show let's see what he's about
so we're making whatever money we lost
back not all of it but we're
starting to make that back is like yo
this is a big show now
i think you have a pr push that there
might be a little interest for the first
episode but
the first few let's see what he's got
whereas if ellen just bowed out we
wouldn't give a [__] about james corden
what do you have to say
yeah you could use the pr you could use
the pr for sure
but i really think it's about like when
you start making money for people then
all of a sudden it's quiet that's what
happened with ellen
right she not paying her staff and all
of a sudden everybody on her staff is
like oh yeah she's a [__] you stopped
you stop making money from [__]
they stop protecting you as long as
you're making money for people
they're gonna protect your ass because
they're protecting themselves
and i don't even know if i don't even
really find fault in that to a large
degree i it's like
that's the nature of the world i want to
judge it but we're all going to do the
same [__] and i think that's where these
conspiracy kids get [__] up because
they go oh man they set up to me
too they lied about the [__] [__] to
make ellen look crazy they stopped
protecting it
right it's like mob stuff like this
exactly that's it it's like
it you could keep someone safe right you
don't think that it's gonna land on some
manager's desk
the rumors if every open micro is
hearing about it
for sure the managers are hearing about
it yeah and then certain conversations
are had and that's my theory always with
louis the second louis started
self-producing specials the second louis
started self-producing a sitcom
he whatever that [__] show was rick
and morty or some what was it called
louie louis did no no there was another
show he did where he produced his own
sitcom
y'all remember the name it's like two
people's names
these are popular shows or maybe it was
that one i don't know not rick and morty
that's a cartoon
yeah but it's called something doesn't
matter the second he started doing his
own projects
right potentially cutting out these
networks potentially cutting out these
people who's all around ticketmaster
kind of protected him
second you start cutting people out
especially the people that have
protected you
from your [__] [__] all of a sudden
they're gonna be like wait why if i'm
not making money why am i protecting
them yeah
be my guest what's the name of the show
horus and pete horace and pete
orson pete i'm telling you bro that's it
that is it the second you stop making
[__] money they stop protecting
you
yeah i could see that and they could
just be like oh we know a guy the new
york times you want a massive story
here you go here's the girls talk to
them see what happens see what they have
to say
we'll stop paying her we'll say you know
i mean if they're doing that
save a little money there let's go
you